- Did you ever feel like
you were loved as a child?
- No.
No.
And because I had never had been
I didn't really miss it either.
You know, I really
to this day I probably still
don't know what love is.
- All right, BJ.
- Yes.
BJ, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Hollywood
and I've been in San
Francisco for like 30 years.
- Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
growing up as a child.
- I had no family growing up.
- Where were your folks?
- I have no idea.
I still don't know them.
- So you never knew your parents?
- No.
- Who raised you?
- I grew up pretty much in juvenile hall.
I'd go in and out of foster homes but
something bad always happened
and I always ended up
back in juvenile hall.
So juvenile hall became home to me.
And after awhile I got to where that's
where I wanted it to be.
You know, everybody else
will go to juvenile hall and
run away to get out.
I used to run away from
foster homes to go back
to juvenile hall because
it was where I knew,
where I was comfortable.
- What kind of childhood did you have?
How would you describe it
- Alone.
Very unstable.
I was never in any one place
for more than two or three months.
- Did you have any
traumatic events as a kid or
any abuse?
Anything like that?
- Yeah.
I got thrown through a wall
one time for wetting the bed.
I was thrown from the bedroom
all the way through the
wall into the living room
because I wet the bed.
I was like eight years
old and I wet the bed
and the foster family
didn't like that too much.
And I had one foster
family that the only reason
they even had any foster
kids were so they had
somebody to beat on
and they used to beat us mercilessly
for no reason, pretty much every day.
And most of the foster
homes that I ended up in
they only had us there
so they could get paid
cause they get paid a certain amount
of money for each kid they have.
And some of the foster homes had like
eight, 10, 12 kids that
they didn't care about.
It was just about the money.
So I mean,
I had a good childhood
in the sense that
I didn't have any,
anybody telling me
if you don't finish your
dinner you gotta go to bed,
but at the same time,
I didn't have anybody telling me
here's your dinner, enjoy it.
(chuckles) You know?
I didn't even know if I was
going to have something to eat
or not.
- Did you ever feel like
you were loved as a child?
- No.
No.
And because I had never had been
I didn't really miss it either.
You know, I really
to this day I probably still
don't know what love is.
I believe I'm starting to love myself.
I haven't been locked up in over 20 years.
This is the best I've
ever had my life together.
You know?
I've got a permanent
place to live, I pay rent.
I've got
TV.
I've got a
nice room.
About everything in my room
is bought and paid for.
I've got a nice towel, a
nice entertainment center,
three cats who love me.
- This is the best point
in your life so far?
- Yeah.
- How old are you?
- 62.
- 62?
- Yeah.
- And what was the worst
point in your life?
- LA County jail.
- What were you in jail for?
- These pills and prescriptions,
doctors prescriptions
for different drugs in Hollywood.
And for a white boy to
go into LA County jail
with swastikas all over
him, oh, it was ugly.
Every time my door got
open for dinner or shower
or anything, at least three
black guys would rush in my cell
and beat the dog shell out of me.
Every time I saw a guy open that happened.
And there was nothing I could do about it.
I was the only white
boy on the whole terror.
That was the ugliest time of
my life that I can remember.
- Tell me about the swastika
tattoos on your chest and arm.
- I went to prison,
I went to Tracy when I was 17.
and at that time Tracy was
it was called the gladiator school.
It was where the really
rough cases started out.
They would go to Tracy and
learn how to be a convict
and then go from there
to either San Joaquin or Folsom.
And I went in a pretty boy from Hollywood,
17 years old
and I was stabbed.
And I didn't wanna get raped
and I didn't wanna have
my shit taken from me.
I was offered an opportunity to ship
up with Aaron brotherhood.
I was told, you're white
you know,
be with us,
stay with us.
We'll take care of you,
teach you everything you need to know,
give anything you need to have.
And I did.
And I never got jumped
or beat up by the blacks at all.
But I had to participate in their mess
in order to do that.
I would have to carry weapons
and stab people in the yard.
And anytime anything jumped off
between whites and the any other race
if I was there and didn't get involved,
then they would beat the
hell out of me for it.
So, I mean, it had its pros
and cons, but I survived.
I did what I had to to survive.
I'm not a racists
I don't have a lot of black friends.
I am a little bit prejudiced, but
the same thing that I
hate black people for
if white people were doing it
I hate them for it too.
It's this
negative mentality.
That's all I can say is that's what it is.
And I don't like any
whites, blacks, greens,
purples, or any of they.
I appear to be a lot more prejudice
than I am because mostly I vow round that.
But plus I've gotten to where,
like I said I'm pleased with my life,
I don't bother anybody,
I don't let anybody bother me.
I do my thing and
go my way.
You know, I'm not trying to
interrupt you or bother you
and I'm not going to
let you do that to me.
- How many years have you
lived in the Tenderloin,
In San Francisco?
- I've been in San Francisco
for 30 or 35 years, about.
- And you've been homeless for how long?
- Until
like 22 years ago I was always homeless.
- And now you're staying in one of the...
- I'm in the
SRO, the mission hotel
and it's in the mission district actually.
- Did you come down here for...
- I came down here to get my check.
I have my pays off.
This is right where we're standing
and that's where I pick up my check.
- That's where I found you.
- Yeah.
- Do you use any of the
drugs that are on the street?
- I use heroin.
- How long have you used heroin?
- About
10 years.
Yeah.
And I don't get high,
I just maintain.
I shoot three times a day
just to be functional,
I get sick if I don't do it.
- And how do you support yourself?
- Through the SSI
Plus I'm an artist.
I draw a lot of pictures
for a lot of people and
different things present itself.
You know, there's people
that just find stern
and they'd look at me and,
hey will you escorting me to go shopping
or will you escort me to pick
up my check or wait around.
I usually get paid $50 for that.
And that happens two
or three times a week.
- Have you ever been in love before?
- I don't think so.
- And you have no kids?
- No.
No. I won't have any kids either.
I mean what kind of father would I be?
Yeah.(chuckling)
No.
- Do you have friends?
- Do I have friends?
I have acquaintances.
I don't think I have anybody
that I would call a friend
right now.
I'm not that close with anybody
and I don't wanna be cause
every time I've been
really hurt, bullied bad
it's been by somebody that
was really close to me.
So,
and to say the truth I don't
feel like I need anybody
for anything.
I take care of myself just fine.
- Yeah.
- So um,
all the shit that comes with a friendship,
I don't need it
don't want it.
Aint got time for it.
- Given the lack of love that you had
throughout your life
how do you attribute the fact
that you're at your very best point
right now?
- Um,
the hard thing
getting me housed
once I got housed my life has been
so much better.
I'm happy now.
You know, once I got to
where I had a permanent place to live,
I'm not just here for a week or a month,
this is my home forever.
When that happened, my whole life changed.
- Yeah. They seem like
a great organization.
- Yeah.
And there's so much
difference having an address
and having that stability.
That's what it is,
the stability.
And living up to the responsibility
of having a place to
live, it's kinda nice.
You know, yeah it mean you can
be put in a place to live
and just be so irresponsible
you fuck it of, you know.
And I don't do that either.
You know.
So I do appreciate what I've got
and I respect what I've got.
- Do you find having a
little responsibility
in your life gives your life meaning?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- And the lack of responsibility
makes your life meaningless?
- Yeah.
- And plus the things
of the day initially felt like
I've accomplished something.
It's not just another wasted day.
You know.
And that kind of means something
because I don't want to be worthless.
You know, I don't want to
get in the way I want to be
in line late,
but I don't want to just exist either.
Yeah. I don't wanna lose worth.
I have some value
to other people other than myself.
- Do you have hope of getting
off of heroin one day?
- Yeah. I've been off of it twice
and I started using it again
not because I needed the drug
because I was bored to death.
There was nothing else for me to do.
I chase the bag all day
while I'm on it but I do.
And if I'm not doing that,
there's nothing left.(chuckles)
It sad as it is to have to admit
this, there's nothing left.
I've checked twice
and went back to using out of boredom.
- What's the most important
lesson you've learned in your
interesting life?
Just the fact that you
grew up without love
gives you a very interesting
perspective I would think.
- First, no one,
that's really important
Cause I mean,
when you start getting
friendly with somebody
or you get close to somebody
you get sure, you trust
him more and more and more
and before you know it, you're
leaving them at your house
while you go to the store, you know
letting them spend the night
cause they don't have a
place should let them come
over for a shower.
And that's when you get ripped off
that's when you get
jumped on
and that's when you get
people talking about you and
it's very... so just trust no one.
You know.
Keep your distance.
Talk to me but do it from
over there.(chuckles)
- All right, BJ.
Well thank you for coming
in and sharing your story.
And I hope your life continues in a
positive direction.
- He told me what you were doing
and why you're doing it and
kudos to you, this needed to be done.
And you're the right ones to do it too.
I can tell.
- Thank you very much.
- No problem.
- Great meeting you.
- You too.
It really is.
- Thank you.